-Our next guest is a Grammy
Award-winning country music
star. Her cookbook, here it is
right there.
"Y'all Eat Yet? Welcome to
the Pretty Bitchin' Kitchen"
is available now.
Please welcome to the show
our friend Miranda Lambert,
everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome to the show.
You've been here three times
performing for us.
It's the first time
we get to chat.
I'm so happy to be
doing this with you.
It's a wonderful book,
not just recipes.
Also a great many stories,
it feels like.
Is that what made it fun
to not just write
a conventional cookbook,
but one that you got
to tell about yourself
and the people in your life?
-Yeah, I've never
written a book.
I mean, I'm a songwriter,
so it didn't seem
that hard till I started.
I was like, "Oh, man, this is a
totally different ballgame."
-Really? Because
you don't have to --
You never have to rhyme
in a cookbook.
So that seems like
it should be easier.
-It's not three minutes long.
It's like, yeah, it was --
It was a journey. We've been
working on it since since 2020.
So my co-writer Holly Gleason,
like, made sense of my stories
and my redneck way
of telling them.
So that's -- she made it
all make sense.
-But some wonderful characters
who find their way
into this cookbook.
Your mother, Bev -- great mom
name, Bev, let me say.
-Yeah.
-Grandmother Wanda.
Maybe even better.
-Yep.
-You also talk about sort of
a group of friends,
women friends of your life
that you referred to as
as the Ya-Yas?
Am I saying that right?
-Yeah.
So my grandmother had
this big group of girlfriends
that we called the Ya-Yas.
They were generation
one, we would call them.
And my mom and her best friends
were like my aunts, basically.
They raised me.
So it's basically just stories,
memories, like, growing up
with a group of strong women
around me like that.
It really prepared me
for the world.
And, like, I've been in the
music industry for 20 years,
so I feel like
without their wisdom,
I don't know
if I could have made it.
But this is like --
it's more stories
I've never shared with anybody.
I mean, I'm really honest
in my songs and my records,
but I've never put some of these
really personal stories
and memories out there.
And there's just recipes
to go with it.
And the recipes are like
very approachable recipes.
They use like butter
and Velveeta and stuff.
[ Laughter ]
-Anyone can do it.
-There was a very novel recipe
for how you used to --
I guess you would
do this growing up --
how you would make omelets
for camping trips.
-Yeah.
-This was tricky.
Obviously, when you think
about making an omelet
on a camping trip, you're like,
"That'll never work.
You got to bring
too much stuff."
-Right. And when you explain it,
it doesn't sound
super glamorous.
But we all go
on glamping trips.
All these girls in this book,
we all had Airstreams,
so we would go like once
or twice a year
on an all-girls camping trip.
And we like to make it easy so
we can drink more and hang out.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
The Ya-Yas, let me say,
I would love membership.
-Yes, you're in.
-It sounds like a lot of fun
to hang out with the Ya-Yas.
-You're in.
You're absolutely in.
And so we made up this way
of doing omelets in a bag.
I think it was my dad's idea
actually
because we grew up
tent camping, you know,
but now we're like, "No,
we don't sleep on the ground.
We sleep in Airstreams."
[ Laughter ]
But you put all the fixings
for whatever omelet you want
in there, like ham and cheese,
onion, whatever.
-In a bag, in a Ziploc bag?
-You go ahead and you
whip it all up, put it in a bag,
and then you drop it
in hot water and it cooks.
Or you can bring your,
you know, your glamorous --
-So, wait. You have a Ziploc bag
full of just the stuff --
-It sounds disgusting.
We shouldn't say it out loud.
-So you put it in a boiling...
-Can do that or you
can just like -- These girls
are, like, they go hard.
They, like, show up anywhere
with their own electric skillet
just in case anybody gets --
they need to whip something up.
-Right.
-And so we love a party,
if you can't tell.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a whole nother
level of party if you're like,
"I want to make sure
I got a skillet just in case."
[ Laughter ]
Your favorite
cocktail is a bluebird?
What is a bluebird?
-A bluebird --
You can make it with tequila.
You can make it with bourbon.
You can make it with Tito's.
I usually do tequila or Tito's,
and it is a muddled blueberries
and mint and some soda
and a little bit
of simple syrup.
And it's supposed to be
like two ounces of whatever.
But I'm like, "Mm..."
[ Laughter ]
-You're a friendly pour?
-Yeah, I just do
like a six count.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, sometimes muddling like,
I will say,
if I'm behind in line
behind someone at a bar
and I hear them
ordering a drink
where muddling needs
to take place,
I'm pretty upset, you know.
But I would imagine you probably
after a couple of these,
you're probably not putting too
much time into the muddling.
-Yeah, I think the first two,
you should really care.
[ Laughter ]
And then after that,
you're like, how about just
the soda and the tequila?
That'd be great.
-Have any of the Ya-Yas
read the book?
Are they excited about?
-They're so excited.
We're going to do a little trip
we've been talking about.
We're all from Texas.
So we were like,
"Where have we not been
together?"
We want to go
maybe to like Sedona
and have a celebration, just
somewhere different, you know?
But they're so excited.
It's really cool.
I mean, we were just talking.
During 2020, we would get on --
We started this thing we called
the Chopped Cook-Off
where it was just an excuse
to drink together on FaceTime
for like three hours.
[ Laughter ]
But our husbands would
all pick an ingredient
and we would have to make
a random dish
out of the five ingredients.
But you couldn't Google.
That was the rule.
It was really hard.
[ Laughter ]
Like one of them
was like chili powder.
And you're like, I don't know
how much to use of whatever,
so that's what even
started this whole thing.
It's like we started
talking about our memories
and how our sisterhood
really has formed
all of our adult lives,
you know?
I mean, these ladies raised me
and my grandma's friends
raised them.
So it felt like -- I feel like
there's a lot of people
out there
that have that circle that lifts
them up and celebrates them,
that's with you through
the hard times.
And that's basically
what this book is about.
-You mentioned you're
from Texas.
Your husband, former NYPD?
-Yeah.
-You met him here in New York?
-You guys lived here
for a little bit.
Are you Nashville now?
-Yeah, we're Nashville.
We're up here a lot.
We spend a lot of time up here.
We have tons of family.
-How is he adjusting, though,
to the Nashville life?
-He loves it.
I mean, he's, you know,
it took him a minute
to get used to the slower pace.
But Nashville is city enough
for, like, a city person
and country enough
for a country person.
So it's a good medium.
But I love New York.
I had never kind of
got lost in the city
or spent time here
besides working until I met him.
And we had an apartment
in SoHo for six months.
And I just like immersed myself
in NYC and I loved it so much.
-Who's the better chef, you
or your husband?
-100% him.
-But you wrote a cookbook.
-I know.
[ Laughter ]
He says that every day.
He's like, "Cool, cool, bro."
[ Laughter ]
He's the cook of our family.
So I told him. I was like,
five years from now,
I'm calling it, like,
we'll be up here
and I'll just be sitting
in the dressing room
drinking like he is
and he'll be doing the work,
promoting his cookbook.
-Well, I'll tell you this.
Let him know that
if he writes a cookbook,
I promise he can come
on here to talk.
-He's here.
-Okay, good. That's a promise.
That is 100% a promise.
[ Applause ]
You've got the ACMs coming up.
You've got a lot of nominations.
When you go to one of these
country music award shows,
are you someone
who gets nervous now?
-Yeah.
I mean, national television
is always a little nerve-racking
no matter what.
But I love it.
You know, this will be
my 18th year at the ACMs.
-That's so exciting.
-That's crazy.
And Nashville,
the country music community
is so supportive and friendly.
And like, people always ask me
like, "Is everybody
really that nice?"
I'm like,
"Yeah, we kind of are."
You know, it's like
we're friends.
Friendly competition, but
everybody deserves to be there.
-It seems like it's very hard
to have a long career
in Nashville
where you don't work
with almost everybody
in the business
or someone in their band,
and it seems
very lovely that way.
-It's definitely
a community and a family.
And I mean, I've been, you know,
doing this for 20 years
and I'm still getting nominated
and get to go see my friends.
And it's like,
it's such a good feeling.
It makes me
want to work even harder.
-It's also cool when you
do things you've never done
before after a career
this impressive.
You've got a residency
in Las Vegas.
How are you enjoying
your Las Vegas life so far?
-I love it.
It was very different.
I mean, it kind of freaked me
out the first time.
I, like, went and did a show
and there was no bus there,
you know?
I mean, I've lived
on a bus forever.
And I was really excited,
though,
because we get to do
this crazy production
we've never gotten
to take on the road.
When you don't have to load it
into trucks
every night,
it's a lot easier.
I'm like, "More fire!
More confetti!"
So, like, I just got to take
everything up a notch.
And being a Texan, like,
there's no such thing as too
much in Vegas of anything.
-Yeah.
-Especially rhinestones.
So I'm like -- I took it --
I took it all the way
to the next level.
-No one will leave
your show in Vegas and go,
"I thought there'd be
more rhinestones."
Is that what you're saying?
-Nope. They will not.
-You also have a wonderful --
I want to get this right,
your charity
MuttNation Foundation.
-Yeah.
-Can you tell us a little bit
about what you're doing
with MuttNation?
Which is a fantastic name
for a charity, by the way.
-Yes. Thank you.
I started it with my mom
and we do a lot together.
-Bev.
-Bev. Bev Lambert.
Beverly June Lambert.
-Beverly June.
It keeps getting better.
-It gets better.
-You can't beat Bev Lambert.
There's a June in the middle.
Well, that's better.
[ Laughter ]
-We started it in 2009
just to basically --
I had started
to get a platform in my career
where it's time
to pick a charity
that you really pour into.
And I love animals.
And I felt like
I didn't want to just give
to certain animal charities.
I wanted to kind of --
We wanted to hand-pick.
And so we started
our own, MuttNation Foundation,
and we just basically
raise awareness for shelter dogs
and we lift up shelters,
shelters that need help.
All the money we raise goes
to improving shelters
and for natural disasters
to help the animals
that are affected.
And we raised over $8 million
since then.
So it's been
a really cool thing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Congratulations on that.
Congratulations on the book.
Thank you so much
for being back.
It's always such a pleasure.
-Thank you. Good to see you.
-Miranda Lambert, everybody.
"Y'all Eat Yet?"
It's available now.
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night."